[Music]
we are so happy that you're about to be
on paradise the first question I have
for you is I just need to hear you talk
what's the voice like where are we at
with the voice it sounds like you are we
at like beginning of bachelor season
crystal voice or we end crystal voice to
the second season fans really it's
indescribable
we're healed and ready okay and what
about the glitter are we stuck wearing
glitter absolutely there been anything
else that you've been doing any other
formulas or routines that you're doing
to really cleanse and be ready for the
beach in Mexico you know I think I just
really developed this wrong morning
routine like it was like silly as that
is but I wanna do really clear like
emotional space coming into paradise and
it's kind of work through some growing
pains and so yeah I've learned a lot of
sage girl did you learn a lot of things
you staged what you're so you're also a
lie
have you changed grown learned since
then yeah absolutely
you know feedback is the way that I grow
and I've received a lot of it you know
since the show get me spoken Ari at all
I have a not know will you get an invite
to the wedding you think so
no no no
[Music]